my name is Caleb Dundee and this is game
review thank you for joining me today
we're gonna be looking at another game
from the world number two Fabiano Cara
Juana and this is a game that really
interests me because it shows the
terrifying power of these 2,800 level
players I mean you see a lot of these
top 10 players you know outplay the the
slightly lower rated grandmasters the 26
50s what-have-you but it's really the
2800 s that that will shock you but
sometimes just playing a perfect game of
chess and it's that's pretty much what
happened this game and so let's see how
Fabiana Cara wanna showed his stuff
against Vladislav Kovalev in the Tata
Steel masters tournament so in this game
we saw efore be 5 9 f3 knight c6 Bishop
b5 a6 the main line of the Royal apes'
this Bishop comes to a4 Knight f6 white
gets castled black plays b5 hitting this
Bishop forcing it back to b3 I'm sure
most of you have seen this position
before
Bobby chooses Bishop c5 in this case
white plays c3 of course why it's gonna
expand in the center black plays d6
white plays a4 and this is a common idea
in the ROI which I'll cover very briefly
for those unfamiliar black expands with
a 6 + b5 pushing this Bishop back to b3
gaining some queenside space meanwhile
white looks to prove that b5 there's a
little bit of a weakness a little
overextended and this a 4 move is a very
common way to do that uses b5 is a bit
of a hook to try and open up this a file
and create some some awkwardness for the
black pieces in this case Fabi simply
defends the pawn with Rick b8 white
takes this moment to expand with d4 in
the center my bishops attacked so I move
it 8x b 5 8 XP 5 and here white goes for
the line night a3 and the point here for
black is he's actually just going to
give up this pawn and in return he's
going to make use of the time that white
sponge playing Knight a3 and Knight
takes b5 to create some definite
threats in the white camp and we'll see
what those are momentarily first of all
you got to get castled so floppy does so
white does capture this pawn and now if
you'll notice these two pieces have been
developed a little bit awkwardly so if
you can spot the way to take advantage
of it
kudos to you you've navigated your way
through the opening well I suppose the
way to take advantage of it is to play
Bishop g4 of course the standard ways of
dealing with this pin are to play a move
like Knight d2 defending this Knight or
move like Bishop e2 defending this
knight in breaking the pin of course
neither of those moves are really
playable here because we've brought both
of these pieces out to the Queen's side
and really because of this this pin is
going to be very very annoying for white
to deal with and this is the main source
of compensation that black really gets
from this opening line in the game white
tried rook e1 and in this case Bobby
actually goes ahead and captures this
knight on f3 of course if you play Queen
takes f3 you're gonna run into eat eggs
d4 and Knight takes d4 when black has
regained the pawn and you have some
extra pressure against this B 2 square
so instead of Queen f3 white tries to
hold on to the pond for a little bit
with G takes f 3 and now of course the
problem with taking back with this pawn
is that you weaken a ton of squares
around the Kings side not only is your
King weak but a very key square in the
road Lopes has been weakened that is of
course the f4 square this pawn can no
longer come to g3 so black is going to
try to make use of it with this Knight
by playing Knight h5 and now
historically here white has usually just
played King h1 tried to hold on to this
extra pawn for a little bit games
sometimes continues with like Queen f6
or if G 1 this Knight jumps into f4 this
Bishop comes to e3 and you just let this
night stand for a little bit and this
Knight does give give black some very
nice compensation in fact we see another
Knight actually reroute to the Kings
side and the game kind of continues like
this with white holding on to this extra
pawn and black looking to use this
compensation to create some threats on
the Kings side
in this case though Coppola actually
came up with a pretty interesting idea
it's been tried a couple times
but not too much success really which is
why it's interesting you chose to play
it here he plays the move f4 now this
move opens up the Queen to attacking
this Knight and it kind of forces black
to move this Knight to f4 before he's
fully prepared to do so of course in the
previous line we saw black bring the
Queen out first to support this knight
on that four but now we have to bring it
to f4 immediately and white takes this
opportunity to actually capture and
after a takes F for white is claiming
he's got a nice pawn Center and this
pawn has been diverted to the Kings side
where it really doesn't want to be and
in exchange for all this he had to give
back this doubled F pawn so material
equality has actually been achieved but
white is claiming his Center is worth it
but we'll see here Fabi actually does a
very very good job of proving that this
center can actually be attacked he does
this pretty naturally white plays King
h1 stepping out of any ideas of being
forked black plays 97 rerouting this
Knight to the g6 square before too long
Bishop c2 we do in fact see Knight g6
and now there's some pressure on this B
file that was making white a little bit
concerned it's probably why you played
Bishop c2 as well and to deal with it
black chose to play b4 and I'm not sure
I'm actually in love with this move and
you'll see why in just a moment first
Fabi starts in c6 bringing this knight
back to a3 and now the key break here
for Fabi to really prove the weaknesses
in the white camp is this movie that he
plays right now first he played c6 to
kick this night away but now he plays c5
and this is really the key move and this
is the move that opens up all of black's
pieces this Bishop was stuck looking at
this pawn this rook was stuck looking at
this pawn both of which are adequately
defended by the c3 pawn in this night
which would love to jump into e5 is also
being stopped by this pawn in this move
c5 is challenging all three of these
things unless white finds some way to
maintain the balance here to keep these
pawns and
for Indy for all three of these black
pieces are going to spring to life and
it's going to be very difficult for
white to deal with it in the game white
didn't choose the most accurate way to
continue in fact he took on c5 which is
a little bit of a mistake
so now after D takes c5 the queen is
also added as pressure on d4 and it
becomes simply too much for the white
pieces to handle Knight c4 was White's
choice
so after C takes d4 white does get to
take off one of these black pieces but
now after C takes d4 we see this very
annoying move rook d6 and this is why
Fabia actually has a very very annoying
advantage in this position it looks as
though white simply has a much favorable
pawn structure these two pawns in the
center support each other quite nicely
and you know if black isn't careful
maybe this pawn rolls down the board
sometimes but the fact is this structure
is actually too weak to to stand white
cannot maintain both of these pawns in
the center and of course it'd be a huge
mistake to play move like d5 the reason
being this bishops going to be terrible
on c2 stuck behind these two pawns and
of course d5 this Knight is very happy
to jump into this e5 square and this is
simply going to be a horribly painful
endgame to have to play with white in
fact it might just be technically losing
and practically this is almost unwhole
dabble you just have to play so
passively and black can do whatever he
wants on the Kings side bring the pieces
around through the Queen side it's going
to be awful nobody wants to play chess
like this so in the game white tried to
hold on to this pawn a little bit but
Bobbie found a very very nice resource
to maintain the threats to d4 now I will
say if Fabi had wasted some time here
played a move like h6 white is simply
much better the reason being he has this
move e5 this move opens up the bishop
and actually does make use of this
Center quite effectively with this
Bishop hitting this Knight this Queen
can come in to support the attack as
well this pawn threatens to come to e6
to break open the light squares and
white is simply crushing so what black
needs to do is find some way to
this pond from coming to e5 and to
increase the pressure to d4 if you want
to pause the video at home to try to
find it you're more than welcome to do
so okay here's the answer it is Knight
e5 of course my favorite way to prevent
moves and chests is to make them illegal
ninety five makes a5 highly illegal so
it's highly unlikely that Kovalev would
try to play it here
of course this move takes advantage of
the pin on the D pawn with this fork
hitting the White Queen white continues
with f3 and now the second point of
whites of Bluff fabi's play is to play
knight c6 increasing the pressure on d4
there's simply no way to defend this
pawn anymore so white has to make a
decision
you can either play d5 and go in for
this awful-looking endgame that we just
talked about or you can play the movie
played in the game 'if I've giving up
this pawn in exchange for opening up
this bishop but the fact is it's simply
not enough here the extra pawn is very
good for Fabi which will see Queen h4 a
nice idea to unpin by putting pressure
to this e1 rook we see rook g1 this
shirt comes to d8 now hitting this Queen
so the Queen comes to f1 simply g6 for
Fabi
now after rook G for Queen e7 rook F for
Queen takes e5 and it's very very clear
that that Fabi is technically winning
here rook h4 is his idea but this King
is simply too weak this night is too
active and this rook is is too close to
getting into the game we see 96 come
onto the board this jerk drops back to
h3 but now this Knight comes into f4 and
the shirt comes into d2 and white
actually went ahead and resigned this
position there's simply way too many
threats to deal with for example Queen
d4 and rook d1 as a threat Queen B 2 and
rook H 2 is a threat Queen h5 and Queen
H 2 is a threat
way too many threats white can't stop
all of them so Koval I've went ahead and
resigned here and like I said this is a
very impressive game from Fabi really
from the opening Fabi had the advantage
after f4 and he never really led up
proving why he's a world-class player
one of the
best of all time playing perfect games
of chess like this who can really doubt
his abilities these days thank you very
much for joining me on this episode of
game review my name is Caleb Denby and I
will see you next time